It turns out that it depends. Let's see why. We saw earlier that Carnival
charges $10 for a registration fee, and $10 per hour for renting the car.
Rent-a-car charges $30 for a registration fee, and $6 per hour, or x, that we
rent the car. This would be the total cost. Let's see a table of values and
these two equations graphs. Here are our two equations and the lines for our
graph. And here's a table of values. X was the number of hours of renting the
car, and this y represents the cost for a Carnival car rental. The second y
represents the cost for a Rent-a-Car, car rental. We can see at one hour, that
Rent-a-car cost more than Carnival. We also see that on the graph. Rent-a-car
cost $36, and Carnival costs $20. In this region of the graph, we can see that
Carnival is the better option. It's cheaper, or the costs, the y value, is below
that of Rent-a-car. But, we can see at other times, like 7 hours, that
Rent-a-Car is the better option. It's cheaper. We also see that on our graph.
Rent-a-car cost $72, and Carnival cost $80. So, it depends. Carnival is usually
better for the shorter car rentals, and Rent-a-Car is better for the longer car
rentals.